ladies and gentlemen
welcome to wild ride with stevo and i
don't mind if i feel a little bit
sexy this christmas yeah
dude so what can i say the guy is a
legend of podcasts
and he's on my podcast so let's get into
it
ladies and gentlemen adam corolla
yeah dude yeah dude thanks for having me
hey man thank you for for coming on i'd
like you to meet my co-host scott
randolph
what's up adam hi scott and we've also
got at the front of the van the gorgeous
paul briskey
hey adam how are you hi paul um
so yeah dude where to begin mayor we
have an illustrious history i don't
think we need to rehash it too much the
uh
adam corolla show uh drunkest i ever was
on tv
um i don't think people quite realize
how bloody i was by the time i
i left there from kicking my foot
through that glass table
like i really sustained a serious
laceration and when i woke up in my bed
it was
blood all over the place do you not
remember being there i remember
being there i don't remember leaving i
don't remember anything to do with being
on tv
what'd you do that day yeah whatever you
could ask adam that would be
better than me telling them well that'd
be a good
title for your next book and i'm serious
like i remember
showing up i don't remember leaving
the stevo's story yeah man so um
your last book was the title
of it uh about service animals let's see
it was called
i'll be your emotional support animal
don't wait i am your emotional support
ad
sorry got the name of it i love how much
you
have uh just absolutely [ __ ] on
people and their service animals and and
all the rest of it and i have to tell
you
that i got this dog right here which i
found
in peru i found her in the streets of
peru brought her home
and i just love her so much i have to
bring her everywhere
so i looked into it and i don't know
i don't know if you know this i know i
know most uh
like flight attendants people at the
airport check-in counter
don't even realize that in fact there
is no such thing as official
certification for a service animal
it doesn't exist do you know that
no i i know they're i know there's such
a thing as
a dog like a seeing eye dog
those dogs get get certified but the
emotional support animals
no that does that's like the chupacabra
but we don't
we don't put emotional support right
right i mean seeing eye dog
okay here here's here's the the reality
of it
yes there is great uh levels of training
for uh seeing eye dog however there's no
such thing as official certification
there's no
test to pass to get like a license or
anything like that
and the rationale for that is that um
if there is one uh sort of a governing
body
then that governing body is going to
have like a monopoly over it and and
it's so there's they just don't have any
certification
if you say it's a service animal it's a
[ __ ] service animal
and they're not allowed to ask you what
your disability is
they're allowed to ask you what the what
task the animal's been trained to
perform
but yeah i'm one of the schmucks that
puts the service dog vest on his dog and
brings it on the airplane
well that's why i wrote the book
yeah dude so here let me ask you uh i
remember
being being just so filled with
jealousy when i saw that you were
recording podcasts
in uh comedy clubs holding like
three four five hundred people on
tuesday nights with it completely sold
out
um what i want to know is the mangria
you saw your uh sangria was that a big
revenue stream for you how much
mangria were you selling uh
we've sold a lot uh it's it has been
a revenue stream but uh i wouldn't call
it a big revenue stream it's just kind
of a
one of the many sort of satellite
businesses
i have i just have like you know 11
jobs and that's just sort of one of them
corolla drinks is
i like that man satellite jobs you know
for all the people who have humongous
social media followings it's it feels
like
great you've got a storefront with a lot
of traffic coming through
but it doesn't help unless you have
stuff on the shelf
for sale that's a good that's a good way
to put it yeah
so for me you know i realized
when i was uh let go from my terrestrial
radio job
in 2009 i
went home and i said uh
i don't think there's going to be any
more one big job
big contracts anymore
i think there's just going to be a whole
bunch of small jobs
and i sort of said i would look at it
now
i said it's like a bunch of hoses
that were going into one trough and
some were trickling water and some were
shooting out water a little faster and
then others were like sucking off the
water that was in the trough
you know we have to figure out like how
to get the ones that are kind of
trickling to speed up
and how to get the ones that are sucking
water out of the trough
get those out of the trough and then the
ones that are going at a good flow we
got to keep those going
and that was kind of the metaphor i had
for you know the kind of new world
order career-wise and i think it's been
true with just about everybody no one
does
you know one thing anymore or maybe
mariah carey does
i don't know but after that it seems
like everybody i know is like completely
diversified now
well they say most millionaires have
seven revenue streams coming in
so you know oh do they safe to say
you're a millionaire right
if you have eleven
round it up but yeah yeah i i am
technically a millionaire
okay um i i remember going to see you
perform
at the hollywood improv and um
you had a little bit of a multimedia act
with uh like an overhead
projector very much like you the teacher
had in high school
and you had like a uh it's almost like a
slideshow
of your annual revenue from the
beginning of your career
and i just remember thinking wow like
talking about
uh money is isn't sort of notoriously
sensitive you know and like here's adam
carolla like just
actually [ __ ] showing his his
yearly income and just getting away with
it that was like you're
part of your act for a long time huh
yeah it's in a special
called the not taco bell material and i
think
it's on trying to think where you find
it where do you find that gary
you can get it on uh video on demand
anywhere you you get
specials i think it's awesome amazon
amazon prime i think you can you can
find on
it's it's uh it's a pretty funny special
but it's pretty inspirational too
because at some
point i do put my social security
statement
up on the board up on the screen and we
go over
every single year that is employed and
uh
there's there's some zeros in there and
there's some you know made 3 200
and you know 1984 and there's a lot of
that
and then at some point it starts getting
into hundreds of thousands of dollars
and it's kind of a interesting
progression to see
i would say probably about 15 years
of you know my best year being 23 000
and then all of a sudden it starts
hopping up into hundreds of thousands
and some point gets into the millions
so uh it's it's it's pretty
inspirational and i don't know why
people
play that [ __ ] so close to the vest you
know i i was poor
i started off poor i was poor for a long
time
i worked and was still poor for a long
and at a certain point i wasn't and i i
don't know why
you wouldn't want to see that
illustrated and why it wouldn't be
motivational to you if you were in the
audience oh i'm not
uh i thought it was perfectly
fascinating i thought it was uh
a great show i was i was glued to it
i just you know i i think i was just
raised that way my dad uh
i don't know my dad was a businessman
and yeah he played you know
i just always understood you're supposed
to play that close to the best
and uh yeah so anyway we established
that at a certain point you became
successful
and and uh your career really started on
comedy central right with
the man show uh cranky anchors all that
was
all on comedy central and i'm dying to
ask you
with dave chappelle being in the news
saying
with this boycott dave chappelle he's
outraged that he's not being paid for
for the the chappelle show on netflix
that's what that's all about he was more
mad about it being on hbo
yeah but uh i'm just i'm interested in
your take on that
like uh it seems this is don't watch
that show unless they pay me
but then i can't help but think didn't
he just get
like a full 20 20 million dollars
for each and every special like he's
like a three special deal for 60 million
like like uh is it
is it wrong to have trouble taking that
seriously
that uh he demands to be paid for for
the show that
that represented him paying his dues
early in his career
and if not if not should i say people
should boycott jackass shows because i
didn't get paid
[ __ ] i said it before and i will
say it again i don't mind feeling a
little bit
sexy this christmas and why because i'm
taking care of myself people
yeah i'm caring about my fitness and
and my recovery my exercise
dude it's all about whoop
if you haven't heard about it by this
point then i don't know where you've
been hiding but here's the story
it's a membership program okay it works
with this bitchin fitness tracker
that i wear on my right wrist the
fitness tracker they give it to you
absolutely for free when you join this
membership service how does it work
this fitness tracker it gleans more
information more insight more valuable
knowledge about what is going on with
your body
and it it communicates that to a killer
app
okay it is totally easy to use
completely intuitive
and now all of a sudden because i use it
i know every single night like
what time i laid down when i fell asleep
what different stages i was sleeping and
how long i
slept in those different stages how much
my body recovered
and then when i get into my day i know
exactly
how much i should be pushing myself with
what's called
strain through different physical
activities
now if i decide to get on my bicycle i
don't even have to plug it into the app
because it already knows dude i stopped
cycling
i cool down a little bit the app says
boom good job man
you just rode your bicycle yeah man i
know exactly how many calories i'm
burning through
i know what's going on with my body and
i don't ever have to take this thing off
because the charger slides right on top
of it man
i don't think i'm ever gonna take it off
because i love my woop band and you're
gonna love
yours now how you're gonna get it you're
gonna go to woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com you use the promo code stevo
and you get 15 off at checkout that's
right
merry christmas people go to woop.com
promo code stevo and get healthy man
enjoy your life now let's talk about
this
ripping off people yeah you know i think
there's
two thought process processes and
uh and they're probably both right in
their own way
like on one hand you go well the guy did
five specials on netflix and he made a
hundred million bucks so
what are you complaining about or comedy
central
paid you when you did the chappelle show
and you made tons of dough
so what are you complaining about you go
all right that's that's a sensible
argument and then the other
argument is well but if other people are
profiting
off of something you created and they're
getting rich off it then why are they
getting rich off it and not
letting you wet your beak and they're
both they're both arguments
they're both sort of sensible arguments
you know either way
um and and i i guess both arguments are
right
um either way all entities here
are doing you know whether it's netflix
or comedy central or hbo or dave
chappelle
they're all doing exceedingly well so we
shouldn't give a [ __ ] about
either one
right uh i wonder is hbo
i know netflix isn't netflix like
losing money like they're just in
incredible amounts of debt and
you know like i think that i think the
idea behind that was
they said they were losing money because
they kept acquiring
titles right so they would show a loss
on paper but their net worth just keeps
growing
and growing and growing because they
have all those assets now but they're
spending money to buy all these things
up
right from what i understand it i mean
they're not if
queen's gambit is getting 62 million
households households like they're not
poor
yeah [ __ ] you know um
so uh what do you have um as one of your
revenue streams right now i know you
were
doing the catching a contractor which is
just [ __ ] fantastic
like uh and then you had other shows
around um
cars and racing cars like are
are you still in the television
production business at this time
um i have a company called uh
chassis c-h-a-s-s-y
media and we do a lot of documentaries
and um a lot of them are about
automotive racing or
guys we have i think three up on netflix
right now actually we have um
the 24-hour war which is basically ford
versus ferrari le mans
that movie we did the dock before the
movie
uh we did one called the shelby american
which is a story of carol shelby and
other ones called uppity which is uh a
doc about the
first black race car driver at indy so
done those i did uh winning the racing
life of paul newman
which is just about paul newman's racing
career
i saw that that's fantastic yeah thanks
yeah i have a bunch of his old race cars
and then i races old
race cars and vintage races so i've
done that winning is on amazon prime as
well so i'm told
so um and we've got a bunch of other
docs
coming out not necessarily automotive
related
so um that's one thing that i do
which is production and make
documentaries
uh there's a couple of tv shows out
there
that were in the talks about me hosting
like
home improvement kind of stuff and crank
yankers is back up
in production now so i i live kind of
half
let's say half i i got like one foot in
the
like sort of traditional media old
school
comedy central you know let's let's make
a
let's make a big tv show and you know
sell it to tlc or something but
mostly i live in the write the books
make the docs do the podcasts do the
through the live show world and how many
podcasts
do you have going i guess i do about
five or six different podcasts
a week and uh my show i do on a on a
daily basis so
maybe i do about 16 podcasts
a week or something every storefront he
has has
seven storefronts is there a record i
know you held the guinness record for
like most downloaded podcasts but is
there a record for
like most hours recorded of your voice
or something like that that you're maybe
up for um
i think paul harvey has that the uh old
time oh you guys can google paul harvey
and then he'll have a laugh
um let's see not that i'm aware of
although i
do i have managed to
to turn podcasting into just a regular
kind of full-time job i mean
sometimes last week i think i came i did
seven podcasts in a day last week and i
i rolled in here at
you know ten minutes to nine and i
rolled out of here at
four o'clock and i've just been
podcasting the entire day so
it is for me turned into
like a bit of a job just a kind of a
full-time
regular regular job it's like a nine to
five of your 11 revenue streams is
podcasting what consumes the most time
yeah podcasting is is the most regular
thing i do
and brings in the most and the other
stuff is just stuff i'm trying to keep
on top of
in between the podcast do i remember
that you
started your own podcast network
maybe you started out with westwood one
corolla one
uh corolla digital was yeah my my
very earliest uh thoughts
were well if i'm doing a podcast
it's called ace broadcasting i guess i
was doing uh
looking down at the screen when i when i
started off
you know i don't know 12 years ago i was
thinking uh
started doing my podcast but shortly
thereafter i
started to think well i like cars maybe
i should do a car
related podcast on top of the podcast
i'm doing
and then i thought well i like home
improvement so maybe i should do a home
improvement
podcast on top of the podcast i'm doing
and then it just kind of spun
into into that so when you were doing
podcasts
when you were doing terrestrial radio
was that your only gig or did you were
you still always doing a bunch of stuff
cause i remember you had the boxing
documentary a long time ago was that you
uh i remember you promoting that that
was a feature that was just a regular
uh rom-com yeah i made that
yeah i made films uh here and there
i did tv shows um yeah i always did
i always did terrestrial radio and i
always then did
shows as well mtv shows uh
k rock sorry uh um comedy central shows
yeah i i did i did shows while i was
while i was doing terrestrial radio
and movies and uh
no i didn't i wasn't doing books back
then where does this work ethic come
from were you always working hard like
as a kid in like school or is this like
anything they
not have to deal with school or yeah
like where does this work ethic come
from
i wasn't uh by the way the boxing movie
was called the hammer
that's right certified fresh on rotten
tomatoes
i uh now i didn't i wasn't much of a
student
at all uh i wasn't good at school i was
a poor student i i didn't have much of a
work ethic as it pertained to
scholastics
i i played football and i worked pretty
hard
to play sports so i got a kind of i got
a strong
base of what it was like to kind of
sweat it out and really work hard
from playing so many years of of
football
uh then later on when i got out of high
school
i didn't i didn't go to college and i
didn't really have a career or
any any path to go on so i started
working
on construction but i was really just a
labor
i just you know dig dug ditches and
cleaned up garbage and moved drywall and
did [ __ ] like that
and i was sort of like
i was getting you know seven or eight
bucks an hour and
i just kind of figured that if i work 40
hours a week i'd
walk out of there with 250 bucks after
taxes or something like that but if i
work
a 50-hour week i'd get out of there with
like
318 bucks or something
and i just started i wanted to work a
50-hour week i just
i just wanted more i just wanted more
[ __ ] you know more
more i wanted to survive
and uh so then i i i
worked pretty hard and i also realized
that
being a laborer sucked on a construction
site just
dirty and hot shitty and just digging
ditches all day
so i was like i got to figure out a way
to be a carpenter
and so i started working kind of hard
trying to
learn carpentry and apprentice with the
with the carpenters and and that kind of
stuff and i and i work my way up to
carpenter you know fairly quickly maybe
maybe four years or something like that
and then i started realizing well i
could do like side jobs on the weekends
and make some cash and
and i i wasn't really i wasn't really a
hustler but i was a super hard
worker like i always was willing to get
up
on a saturday and go put in you know go
make someone a ready or a redwood
dog-eared
fence or something in their backyard
seems like i could make like 100 bucks
so i i did a lot of that and then when i
when i got into
show business i just kind of took that
same
mentality to show business did the other
people in show business around you like
not share that ethic was it
like frustrating for you or did you kind
of find like-minded people there
hollywood divas now i told you i feel
sexy this christmas but i also happen to
feel very
generous because i decided that the
loyal listeners of the wild ride podcast
should not get just 10 off my online
store
not 20 but 30 off of
all physical products available at
stevo.com
now note there are two different stores
on there
there's the naughty store with the
merchandise for adults only
that's where you get your autographed
dick pics
and how are you going to get 30 off of
every physical product
in the naughty story and the main stevo
store
huh glad you asked you're going to use
the promo code
stevo claus and that promo code is going
to work
until the rest of the year for the
entire rest of 2020
that's like what eight days or something
about eight days yeah that means
you get 30 off if you use the promo code
stevo
claus and hurry up because it's only
good for the rest of the year
yeah dude now let's get back to work
well you know the two guys that i
basically got started with
was jimmy kimmel and dr drew huh
yeah dr drew and jimmy and dr drew and
jimmy both have an exquisite
work ethic they're both
super [ __ ] hard workers and you know
like
drew didn't even really look at himself
as a entertainer or broadcaster he like
looked himself as a doctor
who was just on was on call all the time
and just whatever you told him to do
he just he just do it so drew has that
he had it he still has it uh jimmy
was that way too jimmy was like he
wasn't really a stand-up
and he wasn't really a writer and he
wasn't really a host he was just a guy
who facilitated things made things
happen
had ideas you know i guess he was a
producer but he wasn't a producer at the
time
and so jimmy has this really
creative this really creative streak
that
that also is is
coupled to this really hard working kind
of responsible
sober like kind of work ethic so
when you hang around with those two guys
you can't really
you can't be a slacker because they're
going to immediately look at you going
where were you you're late
what's going on you know so i ended up
just
hooking up with two of the hardest
working guys in show business
and honestly i just didn't want to
disappoint him like i looked at myself
as kind of a
shitty student loser you know
construction
labor guy and i was like oh boy i better
fake it till i make it like i don't want
these guys
i don't want to hold these guys back i
don't want to think i'm late
or lazy or anything so i just kind of
upped my game
being around them nice that's cool i
remember being in
i dropped out of college when i was 19
to become a plumber and i would always
drive around
listening to your radio show and i knew
that you were a construction worker and
i was like
all right cool this this job sucks so
bad but you know adam did it you know
now he's successful so maybe
you know i have a chance to not do that
and then i quit a month later but
you know it it was just always uh
yeah i just remember listening to you
back in like [ __ ] what was that like
oh 304 and just kind of you know
but plumbing's got to be the worst job
out there you know it's a shitty job
somebody's got to do it
plumbing's bad but it pays better than
many of the other trades well i i was
the snake guy
so like the ruder guy so i had to go
around and snake [ __ ] out
you know it but it was a free estimate
so you drive all the way out there
and they can tell you no but you know i
got 30 of the bid
and so if i if i didn't get the right
price i'd have to drive all the way back
so i'd do it for
nothing you know yeah but it's good to
have i've
i i used to clean carpets and that was
the same kind of shitty job
and uh it's good to it calibrates you
though right
you go okay this is what i don't want to
do
like i know what [ __ ] work is like i
know
what it's like to work and i don't want
to do that ever again
what's funny is steve i feel like you're
such a hustler and hard worker too but i
don't think you
did you ever have a job like a plumber
or anything like that
i got fired from every single job that i
ever had
yeah where does your ethic work ethic
come from obviously
i'm just such an attention [ __ ] and and
i want everyone to
to know about me in some capacity and i
just i'm persistent
yeah ah so i i wonder when you were
saying you think everybody's got
uh so many different you know revenue
streams and jobs
is jimmy a one one job guy
does jimmy had to do a million different
things
yeah jimmy does a million different
things he always he always has done
a million different things so he's he's
not you know i think everyone has
one job that maybe they're known for
or that's their main revenue stream but
jimmy does a lot of producing and
writes children's books and has many
many irons in the fire
yeah and and everybody of all three of
you guys
are family men how many kids do you have
two
i have twins two kids oh wow you've got
twins drew's got triplets huh
um yeah yeah how long have you been
married
18 years wow i've been now
uh i'm coming up on engaged for three
years
he's gonna be engaged for 18 years in
the next 15 years
yeah have you guys how long what's the
protocol on how long you have to be
engaged yeah how long were you engaged
when you got engaged
six months oh man i i
can't recall but i remember i was
engaged for
uh maybe like a year and then i broke it
off
and then uh about a year went by
we weren't engaged and we got back
together and got engaged again
and then got married but i can't
remember how long i can't
i can't remember how long the second
engagement was or even the first
engagement because
i'm just bad that way like it doesn't i
i have this brain that's sort of like
i don't know like do i need it does it
benefit me
uh i didn't know steve would ask it on a
podcast so i
i probably should have committed it to
memory but i don't
i i don't have i'm not that way with
birthdays or anniversaries or anything
my thing is just like what's next
get on with it what are the dates like
i'm a sort of what are the dates in the
future not one of the dates
from the past right yeah that makes
sense man
and your kids they're they're the twins
are are
identical twins no they're fraternal
twins boy girl
14 years of age wow
i got a vasectomy to make sure that i
don't ever have kids
um i would uh well it's reversible if
you want
well he saved his sperm too just in case
i blew a load
that was cryogenically frozen and saved
but it wasn't as much if i changed my
mind it was more because i'm sure
there's going to be
some dumb jackass bit that i'm going to
want to
make a kid for a jackass we're going to
make a kid but there'll be some kind of
thing
like everybody like blows a load on a
[ __ ] platter and then we
[ __ ] you know like i dry it with a
hair dryer and i snorted it or
something like that yeah there's the
oaky cookie episode
yeah there's going to be something that
i'm going to want to be able to
contribute a load to and
yeah that's true adam with you raising
uh these twins like you grew up not rich
you've kind of faced adversity and had
to work real hard to get
out of that situation but now you're
raising kids
presumably with less adversity like how
do you kind of address that as a parent
um you know i i it would
be hard to impose a bunch of
gravity on my kids the kind of gravity
that i grew up in
it would just be bizarre to try to
withhold [ __ ] from them um
so basically my head on it is
i'm not i'm not stern or strict you know
i'm not one of these parents that's like
you know
i grew up poor and now you're rich but
you're gonna have to learn all the
virtues of being poor and working hard
and all that
i i basically i'm laissez faire with all
that [ __ ]
my my thing with my kids
and i felt this way growing up but in a
more negative way
which is you know instead of parents
kind of imposing a bunch of rules and
regulations
and here's here's the way we're going to
do it i
try all the time to just sort of lead by
example
you know i just say you know i would i
would leave
when the comedy clubs were open um
i would go out two or three nights a
week to just go do comedy for free
like i'd go the comedy store on a
saturday night
and and i would say to my son and my
daughter like
saturday night i'd i'd say look
uh you know we live pretty far away from
the comedy store
and i would say i'm going out i'm not
getting paid
i'm doing it so i can get better at
stand-up comedy
and i'm leaving now and i won't be back
till midnight
but that's what i'm choosing to do and
even though i have money and even though
i'm successful
it's important that i go out and try to
get better
at this craft and they they would tell
me i'm blocking the tv set and it hit
the road
what i made my statement yeah well okay
that's good
that's right [ __ ] the cocktail waitress
did a 10 minute set
and came home yeah
what do you do if you catch your kids
smoking pot as a parent you know like
what age is it cool or you know you walk
in they're 14 years old
are you pissed are you like [ __ ] okay
well
um you know it's funny my kids and this
new like generation are so
square that they talk about like some
kid who was a troublemaker because he
got caught
vaping you know in the bathroom and
stuff like that and it's like
it's so weird and innocuous but they're
they're
so kind of anti they grew up in this
kind of anti-smoke anti-drug
anti-everything kind of world that
i can't even really like it's it's weird
to them to smoke pot or to smoke
cigarettes or to
you know drink booze or like drink beer
in the park or like all the [ __ ] we grew
up
doing it just doesn't make make sense to
them it seems it seems
weird to them but you know i would tell
them
i guess my pot explanation would be
it's not going to kill you but it's not
really going to help you either
and you know you know you get a little
bit older you want to partake at a party
or something
so be it but you turn it don't turn it
into a [ __ ] lifestyle
because that just becomes that just
becomes your life like you just become
that
that person and i i would feel that way
about anything
booze or pornography or whatever like
i don't know [ __ ] chili dogs like
yeah go ahead and couldn't have one but
don't make it a thing
yeah i i get that did uh
i know jimmy kimmel enjoys a marijuana
cigarette
did you ever get baked with jimmy kimmel
let me think yes
but you didn't make it a thing well yeah
i think i think most the successful
people
we know just have a balance you know
it's like nothing wrong with pot nothing
wrong with
booze nothing nothing wrong with
anything
when it's time to do it but i don't know
the the wake and bake people i just feel
like
i i it's like yeah jimmy likes pot jimmy
would never get up and
rip a bong load and go to work like it's
it's a balance
you know i think everything's a i think
everything's a balance your diet's a
balance
your work is a balance your exercise is
a balance like everything is just this
balance of when is this appropriate
when is it not appropriate whose time am
i
on you know my on my time is it is it
is it friday night am i done with the
week am i in my bathrobe can i hang out
am i going to drive
i'm going to drive the kids like no okay
good i'll have a scotch you know what i
mean like that's how it works it now
doing it you know before you drive the
kids to school in the morning now we're
we're in a situation so it's like the
answer the question isn't like
is having a scotch bad or is having a
bong load bad
it's sort of like when are you doing it
and how much of it
are you doing such a rational take on it
yeah that's why it's like when you came
to his show blacked out he's like
oh hello steve but that's the thing that
it was my [ __ ] plan dude like uh you
were working that was his [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah dude um now uh
when so what do you do for exercise uh
drink scotch and smoked pot
chili dogs lecture my kids
drink scotch um i have
a rowing machine at home and i figured
out
that i can't do [ __ ] on those treadmills
or ellipticals like i get bored out of
my
off my ass but something about the
rowing machine
kind of agrees with me so i will uh
i will partake in the rowing machine
hopefully
hopefully you know 20 minutes 30 minutes
uh night just
[ __ ] pulling on that thing it's kind
of you know man i'm glad i asked
it is it is it one of these like
pelotonian kind of things is it does it
show you like you're going through some
kind of a
[ __ ] course yeah they it's got like
the video screen
and you know the instructor and
everything but i never have the sound up
like i
i never listen to it i i never i just i
just
row for half an hour or 20 minutes and
that that's enough i don't go through
the fast and the slow
and the cooldown and the warm-up and all
that [ __ ] i just [ __ ]
row try to make it uh
if you're going good you can make it i
think about
6 000 meters in in half an hour
but there's a kind of a pace it'll tell
you the pace
it'll tell you the time and you just
kind of try to sit there and get through
it i just turned the tv on
watch the tv i'm not into the instructor
nice man
sounds like five miles and uh i read
i think we pretty much asked this of
everybody but
do you have an online store for merch
and and
and where do people go to get it you can
go to adamkarola.com
carla.com and do you have a good variety
of merch on there
yeah we probably got some t-shirts and
some hats and some of these uh
buck slips i'll hold up these uh
cardboard slips to make your notes on
okay you want to make you want to make
all your notes on a
on a buck slip i i like it and and so
when the orders come in how are the
orders fulfilled
do you good that's a good question we
have people here
who handle that stuff we also we we also
use a third party uh
service where basically it's on demand
so after an order gets placed
then the item is produced and shipped
out and it's done from a third party
location so we don't have a large
stock sitting around right thank you
gary right
and uh you can get my books and if you
get my books you can send them in and
i'll sign them and we'll send them back
out to you
holy [ __ ] that's interesting is that
something that uh people have to pay
to have done no no they just
buy the book or get the book somehow and
just
send it in and i'll always sign them and
we'll send them back
wow that's cool that's uh how much how
much of your time
does that take up uh it varies like if
it's a popular book and it just came out
then we'll get a lot of books to sign
and if uh
but then a few months wears on and you
know they're not selling like they did
when it came out so
you know they just kind of trickle in
and when we get enough of them we'll
just lay them out and i'll sign them all
and we'll just
send them back and when i go out on the
road and do stand-up we'll bring some
books and we'll bring some t-shirts and
a merch bag as we call it we'll just sit
back
in the green room and sign the books and
t-shirts or whatever anyone wants i
you know it's not really much of a
revenue
stream it's more just like if people are
going to come to the show
they want to buy a book i'll sign it for
them if they want to bring their book a
lot of people come to the show and just
bring their book
with them and i'll sign it i'm happy
they took the time to buy the book
yeah do you miss not being on the road
or is it a nice break
um i have been on the road so
i have been doing dates in florida and
texas
utah arizona so it's been a
break in a sense in the sense that i
haven't been
heading out like every weekend or every
other weekend it's been spread out you
know every
five or six weeks which has been kind of
nice because it was kind of hectic
before just sort of working all week and
then going out on the road
on the weekends but uh yeah i have been
getting out there
do you have any dates you want to
promote any last things that you want to
plug
adamkrola.com all the specials on
amazon prime if you go to
um amazon prime you can find my stand up
there if you go to netflix you can find
you can find docs in amazon prime too
but you can find
all the docs on amazon on netflix as
well
uh but you just go to adam crowley oh
i'm your emotional support animals the
name of my
uh book you can get that get that on
amazon or wherever leave a review i'll i
always read them
and uh and and you can go to amaro.com
and i'll tell you where the live dates
are
good man i mean can you imagine me going
anywhere without this dog i mean
that would be wrong no but i think the
dog could imagine it
yeah dude well hey man i i appreciate
you adam dude it's always been uh
an honor to be your buddy and uh really
really glad that we got to do this man
thank you
thanks steve and scott and paul for
having me yeah
thanks adam right on brother take care
guys
yeah for sure dude the timer clock is
the [ __ ]
how about that right there you know i
like to think
that there are two podcast legends and
that [ __ ]
yeah and i'll tell you man i still feel
sexy
i feel so sexy that for those of you
watching i feel like
i just wanna rip off my towel and show
you my [ __ ]
but i'm not gonna do that on youtube you
know where i'm going to do that i'm
going to do that at stevo.com you head
on over there and you use that promo
code steve o'clock
you get 30 off an autographed dick pic
plus it's got two dicks man cause the
autographed
is a dick too yeah all right now hey
enough is enough of that
enough of that in all sincerity happy
holidays
and thank you for sticking around to the
very end you know i love my street team
[ __ ] yeah